you are here that's what a sign I saw at
a mall said to me one day when you're
lost it's good to have that kind of
direction gives you a sense of place a
sense of where you are in relation to
other things well today you and I yes we
are here we have come into this house
the song writer says and gathered in
Christ's name to worship Him from
different traditions and forms of
expression coming together in worship in
this physical place but more than that
seeking to find our existential and
maybe even a prophetic place here and
now in this moment and time for such a
time as this seeking to Ain and gain
entry in a way that has meaning for the
living of our days but also seeking to
understand things of the past the memory
of days gone by the things that have
come before us and of people of a bygone
day in the life of Jesus you heard Luke
for a special time a special year moment
for him you see Jesus entered into yes
that physical place he went home to
Nazareth
but he also went to a physical place
called the synagogue that was his custom
it's not the custom of many individuals
you know when they have a sense about
being in a hometown they may not go to
church but it was his custom to find his
way into a synagogue in his hometown and
in that synagogue at that moment in that
time he read he found these words from
Isaiah 61 the Spirit of the Lord is upon
me sounds like an arrogant statement but
it isn't because he has anointed me to
bring good news to the poor sounds like
a self-assured statement but it's not he
has sent me to proclaim release to the
captives could be considered ego driven
but it's not and recovery of sight to
the blind it's not an eye doctor to let
the oppressed go free not the judge for
an attorney to proclaim the year of
God's favor such a time as this here in
these words he proclaimed to all who
could hear that he was sent by God not
on his own anointing not because he was
all of that and a bag of chips not
because he somehow had arrived at a
certain point in his own teaching in
his own living but more because he was
called by God anointed by God
transported if you will to that new and
existential place that new and prophetic
place operating under the anointing of
God to be a mama folks ooh might not be
considered by some people as important
those who are poor those who are captive
those who are blind those who are
oppressed and brokenhearted you see
those kinds of people take up a lot of
time and for individuals who don't want
to spend the time engaging with
individuals like that it might be
considered a waste of time but under the
anointing that God had given to Jesus he
said these are the folks these are the
folks that I think that God has called
me to serve what a wonderful opportunity
there isn't serving those five types of
people being in that prophetic and
existential place was yes something that
Jesus came to know something about and
he lived his life trying to extricate
those individuals from the places where
they were and I'll say more about that
what about the outcome about that in a
minute but it's the same place it's a
familiar place to Reverend dr. Martin
Luther King even though he was exposed
to violence
and verbal abuse he was exposed
discrimination and disrespect he was
exposed to wiretapping and a wound that
almost took his life in his words and in
his actions King said we are here right
now at this moment assigned to a task
anointed and appointed by God called by
God to do what only he could do and I
want to suggest to you that each one of
us though we may be in a physical place
that there is also that same existential
and prophetic place to which all of us
are being called it's about what life
means it's about what the meaning of
your life is it's about what it is that
you are to do uniquely with the gifts
and skills that each one of you has been
gifted with and i'm sure i have
absolutely positively no doubt that each
and every individual has a unique gift
unique to them to be used in the service
of the almighty to make the here better
so King said we are here but we should
not now we dare not stay here cuz the he
is not all that great truth be told
depends on the day but the here is not
great we must move he said from here to
where conditions are better
to where circumstances are vetted to
where discrimination can end do a
desegregation can end where rights can
be indeed more readily accessible to
individuals so we moved as a society
during his time to where conditions were
better however as I said that he is not
all that great and he knew that no there
were advancements though there were
victories though there were things that
happened in our society that let us know
that there was more equality in the 60s
and then it was in the 50s in the 40s he
raised a question where do we go from
here chaos or community and in that book
by its name he outlined two different
things the here and the we're in the
back of that book there's an outline of
a plan that he wanted to execute but
because of an assassin's bullet he never
got to execute he never got to put into
motion that plan so the question is
still a question that he deserves an
answer it deserved one in 1968 and
Beyond and it still deserves an answer
today it's a piercing that question
where where do we go from here chaos or
community these days here involves too
much violence in suburbs and in urban
centers too much violence senseless
too much economic uncertainty every day
I read the newspaper and there's some
story about how we are teetering on the
edge there was a report that was
released the other day about the poverty
that is in our state too much Economic
Security I was listening to the radio
this morning and they were talking about
the how the defense that would have to
furlough some of its workers because of
some fiscal stuff that Congress put into
place and I say stuff because there's a
whole lot other ways to describe stuff
then if you follow the fiscal cliff and
all of that you know that there's a
whole lot of stuff that happens in
Congress that I can't describe other
than that stuff there's another word but
I don't think I want to use it in this
context I'll just refrain from thinking
about articulating that word but stop
stop it makes me know that maybe we need
something else someone else some new
opportunity to help us deal with the
economic conditions of our days that
leads me actually to the too much rancor
and politics because you know the rancor
is connected to the stuff the stridency
that on one side on the writer on the
left and people lamenting that there was
a time when Congress and people who are
in political power were able to reason
together and to come to what was best
for the country rather than best for
political party stuff rancor
where do we go from here too many
disparities and health I'm involved in
health advocacy some of the time we read
stories about the disparities that are
there based on income based on race
based on circumstance too many
disparities to count too much chaos and
yes not enough community and when I've
talked about community you know the word
is together in unity but I don't really
mean unity I mean I don't mean unanimity
because you know just as I'm Baptist so
they say if you're Baptist and there are
three people in a room there for
opinions so I'm not looking for us to
all think alike and to act alike and not
necessarily to believe alike because
it's an individual journey but there
ought to be a way that we can come
together in community to answer the
question and to put forward an agenda
for this time that helps us to get to a
better place than the here moment that
we are currently in you see staying in
that place of chaos staying in that
place where we were or are is no more an
option in the days of Martin Luther King
load in the days of Jesus we must move
from here so that people folks that were
of concern to Jesus and concern to his
servant Martin could hear good news
because mostly it's news or bad news but
the good news is not just about what is
happening here and now it's about the
liberating word that comes through Jesus
Christ that helps us to know that there
is a hope beyond the circumstance in
which we presently find ourselves that
there is a possibility that we can have
joy in our hearts and rejoice in the
Lord always good news
and in the Christian tradition it is
that Jesus Christ is Lord and that he
has come to set his people free that he
is living out that prophetic word in
Isaiah that says this is the assignment
that I have been given and you will be
better off if you embrace the word that
I have he says I will you can do things
more abundantly and there's more to say
about the mission of Jesus but I want
you to know that the good news is really
good news it's news about transformation
liberation sanctification it's good news
but it's not just that he wanted to give
the outcome was good news that there
would be some individuals who were blind
who could see and that site is not just
a physical sight it's about spiritual
insight it's being able to see things
and to see your way out of things and to
be released that's another outcome not
just a prison reform effort as important
as that is it's about being released and
able to serve to fulfill your calling in
this time site insight foresight not
hindsight and to know freedom Oh freedom
over me before I'd be a slave I'd be
buried in my grade and go home to my
Lord and be free the scripture says that
the truth shall set us free we don't
have to be held in bondage by things and
stuff and circumstances and the thing
that I like the most
out of the five outcomes Jesus included
that defined his ministry as recorded
prophetically in Isaiah to find healing
doesn't mean that the circumstances or
the pain change necessarily sometimes
when I think about those who are in
Sandy Hook I say to myself the healing
process has begun but the healing
process takes some time it doesn't mean
that the circumstance ever goes away or
the memory goes away it's just that the
sting is taken out of the circumstance
that you've ever had someone in your
family or someone you know died you know
that or if you've had someone who has
hurt you in some way what you know is
you get to the place where you're no
longer encumbered are held hostage by
the pain of the situation that what you
are is liberated to understand how that
prepares you to the next thing that you
are to do or what you do redemptive ly
out of that situation or how you bring
healing to other individuals who have
had similar circumstances Christ cave
Christ assumed his ministry to bring
good news to help people to receive site
to be released from their captivity to
know freedom and to find healing
choosing community my friends makes this
possible chaos will never do that
choosing that justice will make all of
this possible chaos will not choosing
safety physical safety safety from harm
on our streets will make us possible
chaos I won't do that
choosing peace the peace that passes all
understanding will make this possible
chaos will not the scripture says that
God is not a author of confusion and I
had that God is not an author of chaos
that got what God wants is for us to
walk together children don't you get
where we walk together children don't
you get we walk together children don't
you get weary there's a where a great
camp meeting in the promised land we
have my friends a responsibility to whom
much is given much as expected we also
have the opportunity yes it is the here
and now moment in which we find
ourselves but every individual has an
opportunity to live out but calling as
Jesus and Martin King did and even
though you don't think you have anything
to offer you have the capability and the
capacity you may think you're using
every bit of energy and every bit of
time and every bit of brain power and
Yale that you have but there's always
more there's always more and someone
prayed a prayer and song it says fill my
cup Lord let it overflow there's always
more that God calls us to do God somehow
or another helps us to increase our
capability and capacity I don't quite
understand how that happens truth be
told you know when I think about just as
a personal matter and as an interjection
I told the group of students Public
Allies a couple of weeks ago I said you
know when I was in my 20s I was scared
as all get-out to stand before a group
of people call me sweaty palms knock
knees
racing heart God increased my capacity
so that I could not only stand here and
speak this word but I could stand here
without notes and just ad-lib now that
may not be a good thing but the point of
it is is that God somehow as we move
forward and expressing the call that God
has put on our lives for the here for
this moment in time something happens to
us that allows for us to do more than
what we thought we were able what does
the scripture say something about God
can do more than we ask or imagine you
know I mean I don't know how God does
that but I just know from personal
experience that God does that and some
days I just want to say no no more not
one more thing and then after I fuss I
say okay it's good to get that out
because you know you want to be a
willing servant of an able service
unavailable servant you know and
personally I would rather be in a
relationship with God because God's been
good to me then not to be in that
relationship with god because i don't
want God not to be good to me and to
give strength and direction and purpose
and meaning and mission it's a good
thing it's better than ice cream or any
of your favorite foods that relationship
is sweeter than the best pie that you
will cake that you can think of that we
have the responsibility the capability
the opportunity and the capacity within
us to move from the here this moment to
the where
so that the where becomes a better here
because ultimately as we move as we do
as we work as we serve as we live out
our calling in the here and now
something happens a way is made out of
no way there's an opportunity that
presents itself for us to do justice to
love mercy as we walk humbly with God
all we need is to be in that right place
to see the sign that leads to the same
existential and prophetic please that
Jesus and Martin Luther King saw and out
of which they lived that's a good place
to be
so my prayer is that we would all of us
each and every one of us would see that
sign its sign that speaks to where we
ought to be where we ought to go how we
can move from the here to the where to
make a better here it's a question the
question is in the title of the sermon
it's a question I put in the sermon
because it's a choice as to whether or
not you want to go from here to where
God knows and if we follow if we follow
we will note sign that we seek the sign
that I seek is not like the one at the
mall no as helpful as it was for me to
get to the store that I wanted to get to
as helpful as it was for me to get a
sense of the physical space that I was
in and how i would get from that sign to
that store kind of sign that we received
from God directs us to the place where
God wants us to be
from here
to where
to the better here
where he leads me I will follow where he
leads me I will follow where he leads me
only will follow I'll go with him with
him all the way